good morning Hank it's Wednesday
February 7th and it's story day our
story today is called everyone poops in
my pants by Hank green my name is Hank
and I have a small problem everyone
poops in my pants each morning I wake up
and dozens of people surround my house
chanting what do we want to poop in
Hanks pants when do we want to poop in
them now hey hey ho ho into Hank's pants
we gotta go hey hey ho ho into Hank's
pants we gotta go poop now I know what
you were thinking you're thinking Hank I
believe that many people have pooped in
your pants but I remain unconvinced that
everyone has pooped in your pants and
that is true enough for instance many
poor people haven't pooped in my pants
because they lack the resources to fly
to Montana and many babies haven't
pooped in my pants because they're too
busy pooping in their own I'm just
saying that statistically an improbably
large number of people have pooped in my
pants my mom and dad and my brother John
have all pooped in my pants kirsten
dunst was wearing and pooping in my
pants during the entire filming of
spider-man 2 the entire Liverpool
Football Club pooped in my um Bros
immediately after winning the 2005 UEFA
Cup German novelist Gunter Grass pooped
in my pants while wearing his Nobel
Prize Stephen Dedalus is just one of the
many fictional characters who have
non-fictional 'i pooped in my
non-fictional pants Al Roker had my
pants tailored to fit him and then
pooped in them
Vladimir Ilich Lenin died in 1924 but
has nonetheless pooped in my pants
George W Bush is so incompetent that he
failed to poop in my pants although he
did poop near my pants and then later
claimed that he had never intended to
poop in my pants and that no one in his
administration had ever talked about
pooping in
anyone's pants having seen his poop I
can report that it looks exactly like
wow those guys must be selling
the president's war plan people often
ask me hey does it bother you that
everyone poops in your pants yes it does
sometimes something great will happen
like the other day Barack Obama came by
and he pooped in my pants and his poop
kind of makes me believe in America
again but mostly I just like having
people poop in my pants but everyone has
a cross to bear some people have chronic
back pain some people are on Team Karen
some people are Republicans me I just
happen to have pants into which people
really like to poop it could certainly
be worse
it's like Monty Python member Eric Idle
once told me while he was pooping in my
pants why is Hank for the request of
several commenters I hereby challenge
you to answer every single question in
your survey in one video log of 3
minutes and 30 seconds or less yes you
will have to talk at the speed Hank I'll
see you tomorrow